Lionel Messi has decided his next move
Argentina's World Cup winner has
confirmed he's joining David Beckham's
into Miami the 35 year old told Spanish
media that he's going to the Major
League Soccer side but still needs to
finalize the deal Messi who announced
last week he was leaving Paris
Saint-Germain said Barcelona's Financial
issues ended any hope of a return there
he also turned down a big money move to
Saudi Arabia's al-hillau it'll be the
first time Messi has played outside of
Europe well for more on this let's go
live to Miami now to speak to football
broadcaster and Major League Soccer
commentator huanarango Juan Messi then
as I mentioned is given this interview
to the Spanish media explaining his
decision what did he have to say
hey how are you look uh I mean it's
basically simple he he said he didn't
want to go through the what he went
through two years ago when he ends up
going to be so on vacation and finds out
that Barcelona is not going to continue
his really their relationship with him
uh he wanted to have a better more
family time I guess you could say he
wanted to be more with his family with
his wife with his sons and be able to
have a different quality of life and I
got I guess kind of get away from the
spotlight a little bit to a certain
extent but knowing that there will be a
foot Spotlight on him nonetheless being
in Major League Soccer and being the
face of Major League Soccer going into
the next couple of weeks and in months
all the way to when his contract does
end uh the two-year plus one year option
that he does available have available
until
2026. so yeah there's been a lot of
things that he talked about he didn't
want to see other players reducing their
salary for the effort of him having to
come in and he just wanted to like I
said have a different change in his life
he wanted to see his life go in a
different route in his career as well
and Juan what can you tell us about the
deal on offer from into Miami
well as I said before it's a two-year
deal with a one-year option uh though if
if he does exercise that that one year
option he would end up being in Major
League Soccer until 2026 December of
2026 may I be more precise and of course
that would be after the World Cup would
be played here in the United States
Mexico and Canada uh as far as the
numbers they've been talking about
anywhere between 40 and 50 million
dollars a year but it's not just the 40
50 million dollars a year that that's
the attractive part it's also uh a
percentage of the TB rights from Apple
TV it's also Adidas being able to chip
in in terms of Revenue he would end up
getting a percentage of that as well he
would also get a percentage of ownership
on of intermiami and and of course if
you start seeing the complex if you
start seeing some of the resources that
the team does have at their disposal
it's it's a world-class organization
from that end now he does have
challenges on the field knowing that he
will be going into a team that is in
last place in the Eastern Conference
that has about three or four players
that are below 20 years of age a very
inexperienced side a team that has
competed but hasn't been able to get
results and of course there's there's
rumors of players coming in such as
Lando Paredes Angel Di Maria amongst
many others Luis Suarez has also been
mentioned as well and of course the
potential of having Tata Martino
reunited with him as they are looking
for a coach and he is a top candidate at
the moment and Juan as you mentioned
about the U.S co-hosting the next World
Cup how could Messi's move impact that
well for starters it would be a last
dance I remember we were working or I
was in Qatar a few months ago and they
were talking about that now four years
later that would end up being the
conversation at 39 years of age not only
that of course the World Cup is
something important but it's also the
activations of his Brands and also he
would end up being the face of
Argentina's new training complex in
Miami yes the Argentine fa is going to
have a training complex where they're
looking for youngsters to develop and
maybe even start looking into the under
or the under 15s under 17s and under 20s
as far as reinforcements and players
abroad and also it would end up being
Argentina's training camp for that 2026
World Cup if all things do end up
working out
when I'm sure all eyes will be on Miami
in the next couple of days seeing how
this one unfolds one around go there
football broadcaster and Major League
Soccer commentator thank you for your
time
thank you